Twitter was lit ablaze
Twitter was hashtag not my super bowl
team people were furious they were they
were trying to make it political because
of Brady with Donald Trump and here's
the thing the left freaked out about the
Super Bowl left is if you just shut up
for one minute just one minute you would
make more headway than you are now
you're so outraged about everything all
the time that people just can't stand a
good example I think was Friday or
Thursday Trump had an interview with
Bill O'Reilly where Bill O'Reilly said
well Putin is a killer and Donald Trump
said low like what show Edison I'm going
you know what that's a that's an answer
that concerns me I wanted to come on
here today and talk about the fiduciary
rule and Donald Trump his executive
order on that some transparency laws
some issues that I think I don't have a
problem the fiduciary rule if you get
into it but I can see both sides to that
argument I can see how certainly Donald
Trump's voting constituency might have a
problem some of his recent policies I
wanted to come on and talk about that I
was going to come on and talk about his
interview effectively praising Putin but
then left is freaked out about the Super
Bowl because of Tom Brady and said it
was an example of white supremacy see
it's not that people love Donald Trump
if you look at the statistics most
people don't
it's just that they hate you more they
hate you much more you'll see what Jake
Shields will have him on he's a he's a
vegan from Berkeley for God's sakes and
he doesn't like you no one had a tougher
day then obviously her favorite resident
non-white black guy in chief Shaun King
who tweeted out made it political
thought for sure that the Falcons were
going to win sort of thrashing Trump and
Tom Brady only for the comeback to occur
and his Twitter to be wiped clean
deleted all no one had a harder time
this Super Bowl weekend than Shaun King
[Applause]
oh yeah time to live tweet like the
Superbowl
my boys the Falcons are gonna tear it up
like that's what's up like 90% statistic
Brady you're going down here we go oh
[Applause]
yeah oh yeah yeah that's what I'm
talking about you know no to America
white supremacist America that's what
happens like when Donald Trump picks
your team to win oh that's oh that's
nice I'm gonna tweet that oh I'm gonna
tweet that 140 characters
boom [ __ ]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
well where'd you learn from all this
never count my chickens before they
hatched dad that's right
Shawn nobody likes a braggart I know hey
let's break into someone - Zima yeah
that sounds nice that's my right there
you're gonna delete those tweets yes hey
if you like this video subscribe by
clicking the button that says subscribe
if you're not aware of it now there's no
way you're learning the Internet at this
point I'm not going to help you but this
was clipped from my daily show available
exclusively to lotto with credit.com
slash mug club members of your student
military or veteran entering that promo
code it's less than $6 a month and you
get daily content no more clips Plus
this hand etched mug oh I just when I
feel it I got a chill like on the inside